entry-level position by mass three years
perfect that's perfect
[Music]
thank you and have a great excuse me you
spelled my name wrong
Jared jerath with a th that's your
solution just cover it up there you go
adieu
next hi how are you doing today hi is
this um hawk powers am i speaking with
mr. Ian Ling Shiva's Shanahan I'm sorry
that can't be real hello thanks girl did
you get me those copies they're printing
I have some very important people
waiting on those copies in the
conference room I can't believe you got
fake nails you never wear fake nails are
you depressed
ladies welcome can I interest you in
some of our raspberry cherry explosion
iced tea no why are you so happy you're
scaring you're doing aggressive much
actually I have to makes me say that
yeah she smells beer right yeah
I think there's milk in my latte and
whatever happened to the girl used to
work here I mean she's so nice
[Music]
this does not taste like a decaf there's
the situation in the bathroom so how
much can I put you down for Lionel
thousand dollars that is a great number
you're getting that thousand dollars
yeah krystal krystal krystal if I need
your credit card that's for you you're
better than this let it go let's move on
with your life thanks for coming out and
uh as always don't forget to tip your
barista did you get those kite here Beth
you uh finding everything okay uh you
know there's a 50% off sale on pints of
ice cream for the next two minutes if
you want to follow me to register three
Wow
you're nice nothing just do my job
hey hey hey it's gonna be okay
we all have those jobs we hate it's
definitely not perfect but you just got
to keep at it sometimes you just have to
make the best of an imperfect situation
[Applause]
you
[Music]